ciao sappiamo i cannoni forti i buoni
grazie perché io sono una persona brava
che stai cercando a posto siamo tutti
gli più belle ha eletti di ragazzi di
questo nuovo video io sono falliti però
questa è la mia introna arrivare animale
benvenuti parola come siamo nella kiss
challenge che reggono bello io non lo
posso cambiare adesso la stilista ok se
la destra per fare i piatti ma dove
masterchef più o meno e sono meno
pareggia fa cui si prendono le cose non
lo so cucinarlo questo non lo so non si
prova con a cona non so sempre niente
numeri e te non c'è niente su tua solo
perché sono nero uso le mani basta
guardare la messa sulla pizza
ci sono insomma non ha perdonato la
caveremo rimettere pianiga riso carlo
che il provato sulla mia vita
l'isola viso primadonna carne diviso non
sopravviva non sei capace o dei buoni ha
riso prima le gote regola della bistecca
chiude genitura come l'acqua non è
capace riempie mettendoli e pieve di un
tasto commesso visione a bettola che
schifo che schifo metà piacere o la
corte corto guarda top non è condannato
sempre a mio avviso doveva riso come si
prende rocca il piadina che con
l'estintore prendi prendi questo mette
sorriso che fa
il gusto della carne la mia casa delle
più competitive come si guarda come una
teca di daniela carmen poi resta guarda
un kebab perfetto quello che si può
subito di sì ma che ci tiene motivi a
noi ci porti via porti via con la
fortuna pollo ed ecco cosa ci sono i
tavoli che si spostano marcantoni veniva
stessa cipolla passa più caldo che si
mangia in qatar ci può aver riso la
gratis imolese viber di pentiti fosse un
piatto talento che baci pure annunciato
avviato dilata che varrà di altri
cambiate 5 euro piatto aiuti la faccia
cosa piani angelo mai l'unica cosa che
chiedo solo l'orologio ha richiato un
capitolo metto qua il pollo tagliato
madonna che ci ho preso gusto chemical
carlo cracco devi spostarti di temuto
blanda cuocendo qua ok dai bruciare una
micosi che facciamo le altre cose
decotte riletti bossi intanto e piatti
se non e facendo sapeva fare un po il
bollo e ti posso
ecco perché non c'è la cabina comprato
un inedito per legare la immensa per
turno il bullo sun davanti non fatti ma
anche nel pollo che cotto era fatte due
arrivato schifo però è sempre meglio di
te la meglio nel solito va bene ma sacco
di voti va benissimo se non capiscono un
cazzo va bene amico mio adesso che
abbiamo fatto questa cosa ci concediamo
per oggi è che 4 2 scosse tutto dati
farne carne
con il beta da fernando io berlina
capisco più kat bol pedina si capisce
marina aspetta la carne ci fa il giro ok
eletti nella pentola coaches il polo era
pentola cioè io è che sono una pentola
l'estro io qua
ok ti prendi questo che 80 manchi ok ok
mi6 la berlina manca piatto dentro
l'avventura bravissima mamma mia che
scuole che stava bene mi vedesse di
carne carne normale carne roma est e
carne pollo carne normale è qui stecca
bistecca brano che l'effetto vai
convenute vende dai partiti
ok mettila piatto eolica putamen da
mediatori usami piani del caricato
bravissimo mamma mia nei lavori aspetta
questo ha posto la piadina pedina fetta
una mano ne stai andando tila ok
perfetto da mio padre forse un po però
non devi cosa che usava papa ricorda fai
tu io cosa devo fare
un ragazzo straniero e le cose non sono
giunte le porta a piece of hollow di
merda ma merita almeno deve cuocere e
poi non te lo fa mette dentro de vico ci
si scusa tra le altre cose nel mentre
momento sbagliato svegliato nome
ok ma no
18 secondi non sa perché non hai nessun
calcio a cui non posso andare carlo non
posso tagliare la carne io non carne
cruda mitico la carne a cuocere c'è
[Musica]
ma ci facevamo 6 1
non si può infatti vanno indicati da
fare non ha vita almeno una stella cioè
danno dai ma insieme anche due ma paura
[Musica]
ma anche a donare a dragan i ragazzi
dichiara gamba troppo trova che sarei
mai aspettato fra un po primo alcun
ristorante perché l'eroe stelle zero
stelle 2 capito che siamo michelin il
primo livello che sarà primo livello a
questo tipo di tutorial questo quindi da
casuali e cosa fai
cosa mangiano i casi quindi ragazzi io
spero che questo video è spiaciuto
dicono blanco un commento e noi siamo
normali con un nuovo video ci aspetta
aspetta buy come ragazzi
[Musica]